here this is the second time I think we
both complete
very happy atmosphere so so leave others
talks like the new building commercial
buildings are being w be more and what
about is significant new york city in
the Legion competitive and you know
started really development r square
which is an expert financial center and
then going to the men's with a lot of
planning for the west side would set you
were to 35 or 11
site there's been a tremendous focus in
your class with their needs and where
our office market is headed and whether
we have enough supply and work with a
faint partment this is always a major
major concern whether it's 5 office
based and keep us an edge it
particularly would appear so but on
quantity I think they were less folks
place was a quality right in the sense
of what was it about the building's
architectural a technologically
sustainability and in terms of basic
parameters more plates and so forth and
set them apart and actually led them to
be competitive not just because we were
producing space like weekends right but
we're actually producing his face is
badly by the market
and you know today to New York they're
actually hasn't been that much
discussion of following space the
brokerage community drive
right and so you have certain sort of
movement on the standards 45 feet from
the floor the end of the glass and so
forth so that they're you know if you're
really is it that much did you hear from
community what's the air quality if
you're getting three trading does that
space TTYL and also what a distinction
represented here tonight between
multi-tenant buildings which have their
own very specific set of needs and need
the building
that is on operation and how do those
get creative environment in terms of the
end result I mean obviously school like
this for explore our picture here at
Columbia we're always thinking about
that billion first a positive form or
time and what is because of things like
employee attrition in terms of
attracting reporter it because the level
is based pauline space is so significant
that people want to be there
international companies wanna move in
there and so it's these issues that i'm
hoping that our panelists will be a
touch on tonight we have this discussion
the format of the discussion was really
straightforward after i just read
introductions of the panelists they'll
speak for ten minutes each about to
build in some specific choices that they
made and how the idea of animals
processes as i started cornea will be
building in succession for a through
july and august and really go to say
that these buildings were a step above
anything you want to produce priorities
so really
speak to those kind of decisions and you
know things like the break-even analysis
if you deploy a sort of sustainable
technology doesn't really pay back over
tonight the kinds of questions that I
think we're really concerned with people
concerning the moment industry so with
that I'm to do some quick introductions
and then as the United States so Elena
roasters Isco vice president and a
fourth generation family member of the
jurist organization when I started her
career and interent that's brutal park
trust where she not only fell in love
with them to River waterfront but also
gain valuable insight into the city's
complex land use for three process after
studying those gated through college
lena joined the recent Department of the
Durst organization where she's
participated in closed approximately
under thousand square feet Denise
transactions she also instituted a
company meeting of the company building
and operations include landfill
diversion rate green cleaning practices
and resource conservation Lana's
participated the construction and
management several projects from the
ground up including the effective milena
and one Ryan park Elena has a board
member of citizens union just food
governor's island Alliance high school
and stage
hello my name is Elena thirst I'm a
fourth generation family members that
your organization so so we start over my
name is Elena Jersey family member of
the Durst organization and we like to
think about being practices and
sustainable building building off of our
historic our history and looking at what
we've done in the past I'm going to read
a few tidbits from my great grandfather
Joseph Durst Joseph Durst here on all
the right he actually came from visit k
/ Eastern Europe as a tailor he was
actually making children's clothing out
of used overcoats so we kind of generate
we had a history of innovation his
brothers his sons to meet his sons
developed into three modes of
development which was assembling
developer another brother Reuters see
more turquoise dissembler plz sub learn
the developer Josefa Sydney Reuters with
so knowing exactly what's happening
within your buildings and then their
component of course the construction
which is also sometimes the most
exciting so making sure that your
buildings work inside and out and also
looking to that as to what you can be
doing as far as innovation part of that
innovation actually landed us into the
developments that we have currently
mostly we're focused in midtown
Manhattan and that came from my
grandfather saying that you how to be
able to walk to all properties that you
go oh that's part of the management you
need to be able to see exactly what's
going on in your Donuts that is part of
the most important part for management
for us we have our own cleaning crew as
well as our engineers and we know that
people in the buildings are what makes
the building is different and puts us
into a different category that other
land owners managers and developers in
your city so a little bit more about why
we came here tonight to talk about
onedrive park- development one riot Park
was actually innovation of the face to
park my grandfather's ideas of being
able to develop specifically in Times
Square he started buying properties in
the 1950s in Time Square focusing my
specific
because he had a future development plan
that would encompass 4727 street
broadway sixth Avenue I would have
looked something very similar to what
Rockefeller Center looks like today
maintaining a lot of historic theaters
in the mid block as well as having a
through block passageway as well as
about a million square feet of
convention space beneath this plan is
booted foot Fourth Circuit 1969 which
was 14 years before jacob javits center
actually ever came into being well a lot
of development is try try try one more
time until you get it right so it took
us 40 years to actually put this
building up but we're actually better
off than going forward with what my
grandfather's original plan was we
probably have as much square footage
doing two different zoning laws and we
have much much better stock of building
if we even built the building in 1960 on
this site it would have got it for maybe
fifty to ninety dollars $90 square per
square foot mats we were able to talk to
mark it off in two thousand eight and a
hundred eighty five dollars a square
foot and since you guys are business
folks I thought I'd relay that story
it's not only just about sustainable
building per se but what is green what
is green to us it's about sustainable
buildings it's also about efficiency so
going back to my family's history
Reuters and his brothers they put
together the first glass facade on a
building in New York City using the
glass curtain wall system first we used
in New York City they also were talking
about air conditioning to their grip to
their father and what they said to their
father damn you really need to put air
conditioning to the building all the
tenants are requiring it josephs
response was well why doesn't everybody
so home well we push that envelope and
we continue to push that envelope our
first building that was greatest was 44
x squared which is recognized as the
first green commercial tower in the
United States and so it's about
efficiency for us and looking what we
can do with one riot park that would
make it a little bit different a little
bit better than the rest of the
buildings that we had hopefully what is
in New York City as well as the nation
to that extent we did as much as we
could with the bank of america thanks to
the bank of america's putting into
sustainable features we have cut our
sorry dudes like we have higher
ceilings and translucent sleeve yes
which means it gives us the ability to
be able to get expert british per square
foot as well as insulating our building
we have filtered under fair for
distribution this allows us to keep the
chilled water at higher temperature
chilled water is the water that you
circulate through a building that needs
to go passive there if you're able to
keep it 10 degrees warmer that means
you're able to lower your electricity
costs as well as a clover your fuel
usage carbon dioxide monitors carbon
diox-- our motors are central to making
sure that the tenants feel better a
large part of the green build green
building movement is what do the tenants
do how do they use the space gray water
system New York City's by sewer overflow
system that means every time it rains
more than half an inch in New York City
raw sewage is going to
our Harbor we're collecting ninety-five
percent of the water that falls onto the
building reducing our septic system
overloads world-saving tomorrow's Uranus
do you like doing this just means that
we're making sure we're looking for
counting how much we're how much
electrical usage we're using our on
lighting system as well as the oversized
of my phone electrical condom condom
condom occurs we have green roofs on the
system which actually fight against are
at our stormwater system because if
you're have a green roof on your system
that they agree with what you're
building up in you're producing nitrogen
which goes against your greater our
system we also have cogeneration plant
which produces about five megawatts of
energy on site cogeneration means that
it's not only generating power but it's
also generating steam use that steam for
heat as well as to run a chiller plant
dedicated to the building in conducting
junction with our generation system we
also have a nice chiller plant which
includes about 40 tanks where we're
creating i SAT night we're using the
overload of electricity during the day
during the night to be able to produce
lights it's essentially a battery the
battery Isis uses about raping then melt
the ice during the day avoiding peak our
usage peak our usage is when you turn
and content those like
turn on peaker plants as well as be able
to charge you a higher price for that
energy usage in within the building of
course are about many of the LEED
certification requirements meaning that
most of material that we resource from
the building is within 400 miles also we
use recycled content we use several most
of our buildings are made have most of
our bathrooms have my stove which is
made out of recycled post-consumer waste
glass as well as making sure that most
of the materials that we have been the
building if they're not recycled content
from a renewable resource we also have
bike parking within the building as well
as many other features including low POC
piece and various other friends thank
you next friend colleague one of the
many many years sean janno Lieber is
president of World Trade Center
properties LLC janno Lieber is
responsible for managing all aspects of
the silverstein organization's efforts
to rebuild a global trade center site
including planning design and
construction issues business financing
legal matters public affairs government
relations is reliever previously served
as senior vice president of Lawrence
Rican company is an independent
consultant specializing in public
private development issues from 1990
14-gauge we were worked at the US
Department transportation finishing as
assistant secretary of transportation
policy earlier is career mr. parks law
and serving the office manager and
Cochran staff the new public magazine
geosphere talk about 700 km master that
everybody well liquored up during class
I'm like fire silverstein the other
registry properties that I'm not related
and this project is one before we get
into specifics about seven books every
fish
folder but I actually think of it into
sharper focus in this discussion on that
topic of efficiency and sustainability
and especially after your competitive
because this is a real real issue / and
I grew up in the city mile from here and
between 1970 99 New York City produce
100 million square feet of new office
space but you like the design of all
those wedding cakes and rear office
building Southwest directly related to
our success and our competitive economy
grow and grow and expand and modernize
our office product stock a huge
concealer between 1990 and 2008 Dara I
think it was lesson for any moment so we
get into mad brah production is related
to economics strangely we don't think of
New York is a low-cost place for
anything right but in terms of office
space way to talk about a hundred
the nurse building achieved read that
virtually nobody else has achieved more
broadly though the New York City office
market is a relatively low cross market
compared to the world cities that we
took key with London Moscow Hong Kong by
even Bombay office space New York City
so we had low rents we have high
construction costs and very few seconds
work pretty well but especially Santa
Claus post mass transit and the result
is that we have not been producing new
offices even as we are becoming as the
city as economy more and more dependent
on super high value-added office job
Rosana the crazy go so this is a very
dangerous mismatch and one that's very
threatening to our future because you
don't see it every day slowly companies
are starting to think about where do I
put my job's not just do I
across the river because it's a little
cheaper for some back office that used
to be the competition thing but now
we're talking about the top-tier front
of house pumpkins super high value-added
job that all of you are headed towards
and they might be London that's terrible
terrible risk to receive if you're
passionate about New York that's that's
a real date and is in that context that
was unfolding downtown is actually
pretty excited because what happened is
on the backside of the tragedy behind
legend we've had an opportunity to kind
of break that mark of dysfunction
because there was insurance and there
was limited amount of tax free dancing
which kind of changes the economics of
building office building which otherwise
have gone in a convention develop and
the fake American power which which
later referred to also but I don't know
if it was major break for that they were
forces as well but it is a very very
important opportunity for us to get some
new office space of great office space
and produce kind of HPV so with that
long introduction and bring it back to
what we shun maximum discusses seven
world trade center which was the first
building to rise was the last button be
destroyed the left we have the old seven
world trade center berkshire so received
about in the ease in the early days
after the Port Authority finished the
main World Trade Center site so it's
remember they had some land that was
just to the north of the site and great
power heated to a number of Elvis over
students winner to help that building
which was big in footprint and it
actually got like consisted with the
World Trade Center Planet gamma 1 to 10
I second some ways function it was a
successful building but functional
there's a barrier because it kind of
straddled streets
it was a wall he didn't he didn't
preserve the grid which was true the
whole world trade center area after 911
911 the Dozen was destroyed degree from
collapses Roy power night of it and you
see after the recovery what was left and
then shot and right you can see
greenwich street coming stafford have a
run created to set up rep right once it
says next is that are going to push so
but what we did instead of building
exact same footprint we built a thinner
building so the greenwich street for
greenwich street could be reintroduced
and to come back through the World Trade
Center site this was a really important
ideas not only we're going to know the
great built-in colorful with a
sustainable building building that will
be competitively added pages for the
city we wanted to restore the grid quit
this area back to New York on the
streets bring the street backers very
important resulted we got this little
triangle here which we built into a park
is you know this really that is water by
recycled rainwater is very sustainable
equally important
a place of respite in all of the crazy
constructions going on all around
downtown it's one place that he goes
finished and people especially
construction workers can come sit and
relax and just be outside coming back
together it's totally different
footprint as I said I was a little bit
taller we lost about four hundred
thousand feet in the process but it has
resulted in a very successful building
we see it slightly slimmer it's one of
the interesting things about this is
this was done with very little
information time of Luxor was no
priority about what the World Trade
Center site may incitement whatever
become was there was very little fire
about many many things packed and but
there was a kind of sub station
basically when needed to be rebuilt it
was not on the roads outside Larry had
free him and this is one of those cases
where I think I hope it's not those with
the developer of determination and
initiative kind of broke through some of
the normal barriers to getting fell down
in New York and we just started
redesigning we just went like mint
everybody got together on this idea
quickly streets back other than that
which is when was it was a time before
like the dirt building in Times Square
before even the lead system of green
certification is in place full people
weren't cleared on New York Times power
which is successful building didn't even
go through LEED certification it wasn't
fear that that was the standard we too
were developing flux where there was one
certainty back stand but we did it got
it up and it was finished four years
later which we sometimes the bottom mind
but other participants in the results so
open is a 2006 everybody said Larry
about your mind building a little rented
a failure bring the market that is
usually be shocked points out people
think of office space generically got a
lot of words and filled up with great
tenants but most important the
repentance that spoke to this idea that
a modern new modern building the sum of
these efficiencies and sustainable
features was going to be interactive to
the slightly different
I guess it had old financial services
like Moody's in it which occupies about
twenty-five to thirty percent of the
building but it also has attracted a lot
of branding and advertising and
companies that are driven by your break
Carly gotta be sure they want to be here
for the brain power they don't want to
pay park after the edge from rent and so
it really is ability like this where we
can offer a little lower price point
protecting New York's economy I'd like
to believe that we are doing a lot to
protect jobs that might otherwise be
forced out of New York away we're
starting to hear about artists being
forced out of New York these jobs might
be forced to leave the or if they
couldn't find a place that one here to
kind of speech to whether through the
traffic and it's not just a bad fat in
stylish and modern it's also about the
efficiency of new space and I want to
talk about that for just one whose face
is more efficient because when you have
many fewer problems to work around which
you lay out your face you can be vast
rent my space it's a very significant
cost saving factor it gives you more
flexibility
always I I assume that
also don't have a lot of the core walls
which surround the elevator to the
stairs every incentive though I meant a
lot of penetration so you can put your
planning the desks and files and
everything you're doing office space
right up against the horrible you don't
have to preserve the access to the court
so those kinds of efficiencies those
kinds of flexibility are huge for the
kinds of companies that layout very
flexible space so that people can
constantly be interaction and
communicate we don't necessarily layout
space in an old-fashioned way where you
just have one closed office after
another so this is an important piece of
matching up office space flexibility
what kinds of jobs you want to teach in
New York the other thing that's going on
the people are starting to pick up is
that the creative class work versus
driving New York's economy now doesn't
necessarily live for the workforce
pastor they are called Long Island
Westchester and southern genetic are
diminishing as a percentage of our
workforce our white collar crime and
Brooklyn Brooklyn and New Jersey are
growing that is Brooklyn in New Jersey
lower Manhattan for those who are in the
highest end of the spectrum the growth
areas for our workforce if you ask I
think there was any habitat is asked
when people come to
for a place to rent in Europe see where
the wind blows it says everybody walks
in saying they want to live downtown
they are not end up doing that okay all
walking salmon run over downtown that
that's really after New York Magra it's
changed so the gravity is move downtown
and it's vampires more convenient to
that we work force and that is also
supported it's very exciting development
the downtown from the place where was
just all financial services to New long
we have I'm not going to clean and
really covered very thorough sustainable
features that are me buildings have they
they have one thing we do not have which
is a cogeneration plant virus
silverstein & Jerry's fired after
generation meant an old building on West
forty-second Street 11 + 40 seconds from
30 years ago what happened comment is
that you can't produce power beyond the
nine this dynamic of cogeneration not
necessarily we all believe not sure the
content
so one of the challenges we all face
because there's some very important
three initiatives and still go up
against the regular utilities we were
not able to do that just all the same
features that later mentioned and on
topic of how much of the car it cost a
fair amount more incentive motivation we
put Larry interesting leaders to their
credit for visionaries have been
committed involved with the
environmental movement for some years
Larry is this outdoorsman sportsman and
very sensible air quality as
he saw this as a business decision he
said this is coming the standard the
expectation agreed is coming from around
the world European bees are adopted
international companies wanted inspected
and we have to be smart going to see
those coming and it's actually turned
out to be true one of you know worked
with large expenditures that I mentioned
on that was before the bottom west he'll
lead popular mar 07 rotator cuff
resource German investment bank who said
we have to be in a degree know because
that's our corporate so they show seven
so that I think was what was kind of a a
market changer was that Larry was
received our organizations perceived as
business people who made a great
decision in part hopefully not strictly
but large parts of the business reasons
apart from the ideological so the
firefighters are we human is retarded
our competitiveness what's exciting
about that now and why I think it
represents a new model for our city and
we'll make this work presents the urban
bottles we've all been talking it has
the most mastered every subway in New
York City comes in exception the teacher
shows it all comes the lower Manhattan
fairy comes a block away from rivers and
it is ninety-four percent match screams
no other business but you also have an
intensity of residential right around
that for the business so this is a
one-of-a-kind walk to work mass transit
in pencil experiment in having two big
huge 24-7 developed I think that is
going to make our city much more traffic
because people today are moving away
from the long commute model that has
dominated so much of development
national in the United States in their
national and they want top quality
toppers
wants to be not to waste time travel
this is an image of several trade center
in the background the foreground thank
your operation center which is a Tesco
gonna build it by the end of child and
then brand-new condo Bed Bath & Beyond
barn over the whole foods in it next to
it PS 234 which are the numbers it's a
hydropower Frank public school so this
is a really exciting one of a kind
proximity about I think that it will
also be part of preserving as well as
April friends former president of real
estate sillies planting vegetables full
responsibility for leasing and managing
first corporations portfolio
these October 2060 go in the 500 million
dollar 26 during classes kills power
that is the phone first corporation
world headquarters the first goal rated
occupied building in New York City the
Lord Norman Foster design powers to
describe our central critical tall order
the beautiful skyscraper to go up in New
York since nineteen sixty-seven that was
to a rotation in court Wednesday
executive of the year by the national
association of our progressive
executives as a member of the real
estate Florida New York to the foreign
editorial board member of the journal /
real estate and for new phone number
corenet global trade blows all
selections from the American University
and recognized chocolate
that'd be good nice color today thanks
for joining me on the panel it's going
to talk about that first hour and it's
very easy to get to from here get on get
on to school and walk one block over
it's pretty exciting tower visionary
from it's very found the servers mr.
Hearst most of you would know garden the
newspaper and hire some of you might
remember his grandfather who had
investments in gold unique opportunities
in the West but really the world
headquarters for the Hearst Corporation
which was magazines newspapers radio
television cable entities like ESPN
lifetime Amy and many other properties
is here in New York City and mr. Hearst
really was a visionary and he wanted
something in his original building here
in New York which had the properties of
the theater and we're sculpture and it
was an important back a notable building
something that would disdain on the
stand on a conspicuous
well in 1927 that's what he wanted and
this is what he got next to it I think
it would be quite excited about what was
built upon his original foundation both
literally and figure this rehearsal
thought way back when the original first
magazine then he should add extra
foundation into the building itself that
would support a skyscraper going up
about it it's above the columbus circle
station and for many many years this was
the world headquarters of the hearst
corporation they had goodness keeping
institute at the time but it means
basically was a magazine for Esquire
read Cosmo popular mechanics and
entities but 21 years ago I was
recruited to work at Hearst had
background real estate in banking and
politics specifically west high politics
at work from sent minority leader
a number of people in the Senate the 21
years ago they dangled this idea in
front of me you know right we're
thinking about being building a
headquarters what do you think this
could be very exciting if you came to
work with us in our real estate didn't
take 21 years of my career to build the
first tower but it was an idea that came
from a conception and picking on me
sharjah point these things take time but
time and love and excitement and how you
use that when it comes your web and
someone in this room is going to have
the opportunity to have become their web
is how to make the most of the
opportunity when you get how do you
innovate the make your building one next
word is a Hearst name not mine but how
do you make it the most exciting smart
and innovative building possible we were
in 10 12 13 given day buildings around
Manhattan
who can prepare there's just a quite
visionary she's correct when she says if
you can be in the real estate business
if you're gonna manage don't you have to
go around to the UN
you have to become mayor of cheese you
have to know everything that's going on
your building if you're in the facility
area to be able to make it work these
buildings on the Matthew weather where
we're located within the Columbus Circle
campus they grew their businesses they
expanded they bought new magazines make
valued magazines that connect to
internet com go saying erect what what
people is going to begin what whatever
turning out today was a German IDs we
started these incubation spaces and then
some take off in my case I had a
background for a minute or so the tour
we did submit each one of these
businesses and where they were located
we're excited it's a sexy business to be
the sway of those buildings with sexy to
you know the idea was how you build the
workforce for the future how do you make
that work force competitive and this is
even before you get into the new age of
social media and everyone chasing
Facebook everyone chasing Twitter
everyone facing something else is kind
of long I have any opportunity to let's
put this in context
when this happened managing a portfolio
not just kidding around the world and we
were moving businesses out of New York
during the decades administration
Columbus Circle was a message thank you
all these people really wasn't proper
environment to grow businesses primer is
an all-time high on the tired of
Giuliana came into office things started
to clean up it was more of a
pro-business approach to things the time
warner center was under under
consideration and the idea of what okay
what are we going to do
this airspace above all of a sudden
developers were approaching me and
saying 150 million dollars if you get
out of that freaking doing and I can no
contest when something all seven starts
approaching then you realize that airs
159,000 their unique structure you're in
New York City they have because this was
already a landmark Dylan this was a
building that had as a bright and beulah
process the ability to build above it
you say what enough airs worth that much
of New York what can I do with this
again it has been done to you what can
you you go into your boss is the CEO and
etc is in no one the time I was
president of the National Association of
corporate real estate executives to see
we need to start thinking about the
future how to be competitive what the
workforces tour is going to be because
this isn't going to cut HRT nice a
really bright line that ain't broke why
fix it but at the same time is it well
why'd you go forward to see what you can
do with it at that point you approached
the city look at them
oh he just off the old plans because
they tried this three or four times or
thought about it including when mr.
Hurst was a lot we go okay say what do
you think of this city if you gotta
build a better start thinking about
something any data and they say you know
what you really need to be doing this
keep thinking outside of my to be
thinking world-class architects and some
of those exist around the globe her
skiing who they were able to travel
around the world look at architects from
japan to china from germany and a few
americans as well but they settled upon
Lord Norman Foster Foster is an
interesting individual he knew how to
marry the old limited if there's a huge
from Central Park he also had complete
background in sustainability this is
janna mentioned before European
standards are far more advanced in terms
of sustained oh
ideas then American standards were and
this is very important he's spoken it's
very important communication is key
between the client and your architect
and so there were times and meetings
with the Lord neither side understood
what they were talking and we're
speaking English so imagine how
complicated is when go beyond but once
you have a meeting in the moment you
understand your client the client
understands you there's great things
that you can do because if you've ever
get an opportunity like I was to leave a
lasting legacy to the New York City
skyline one would you build anything
less than the very best why wouldn't you
push the envelope to make it the
healthiest building possible so what
that's fun I used to be quite regularly
to have real estate for the New York
Times the head of real estate
and a real estate what I see well if we
were all benchmarking gasket already and
your beautiful powder that's automated
data really wrestled from your wellness
but I could venture on the inside the
point is we're all thinking about
building buildings when you get together
we talk about this we've benchmark
things you public pricing of things and
you go forward you have to put it in
context of the time is after nine eleven
so how do you make me building safe
we're on innovations for safety
especially in a tower the building codes
didn't exist at the time your
communications company where are you
building the wireless technology how
expensive is that wireless technology
why would you shred it for as a building
being said if you didn't do that today
but at the time I she's a liar what's
happen we want to be able to take your
office anywhere for building and it
moves with the ability to bring all this
light open space up Elena talk right now
leed certification at the time you
couldn't find three four people in the
same the new probably little unexplained
character becomes place but Luger we
didn't know suspect quarters to a great
sustainable standards
is leading the pack in terms of where
sustainability would be and if you think
you're going to be able to attract the
best of the brightest the youngest
people and not have an environment which
makes them feel that you're giving
something back to the environment the
jerk breast company that's going to be
far from it that's one of the key
indicators that people take a look at
your licking each other notwithstanding
the second it's a simple thing I'm even
cleaner and adding it more lighting how
do you take care of resources that are
going to so when we bring up this idea
of bringing to your CEO you talk about
the second part that's insane well its
fullest at the farm you got to the point
where they understood by the top of the
building a spa the more i call this
problem a gym for your employees with a
need of a game five different types of
substantial woods even someone so it's
all about edge in your people wearing
stone explains the editors are you look
at this open plan before everyone was
hiding in a Dilbert cubicle no one was
talking to each other they were all
across different city streets so Jan was
talking about how much people you can
get in per square feet you see that
they're only open plan the buildings on
the side of the blast the light comes in
people have views of Central Park the
hudson river and the manhattan skyline
it's about thinking out of the box and
making it trying to come along and where
it
that's what you do the sky is the limit
you just go for it and trying to put
together the right people to help you
you look at examples like Elena's for
Bears who did a fantastic job over at
four times square you look at
developments outside of the box European
developments other places around the
world we benchmark with people and then
you just make your case and America
scanning your C deck lid let me see
Ellen is a longtime friend Medford short
professors real estate development
business school where she director
almost consentir formula skating the NBA
realistic program
12 years we all get to the discussion of
front
Chris
time you were doing something
how fast is this sector make decisions
not that long ago fixing things and I'm
sure there are regard batsman's now how
do you have you deal the fact that
you're trying to make rational decisions
in a field that is rapidly changing
right perception is rapidly changing
their you know when we don't want to
make the decision now how fast is the
technology
twice about in my case I had very few
examples suppose I was basing it what
was existing in very small groups of
California a lot of what was happening
or Germany in London France but the idea
of building a healthy building in a more
energy efficient building is really just
that I think people who work it so
approaching i would say come to Stanley
come to that Dominator system cost one
point why do they go for this but
they're not looking
the better air quality system is you're
going to provide employees and how much
health through their say Couchman yeah
then I get technologies of breaking your
many more choices out there in there
there was a relationship there's a
recent study you know there's some work
at the federal level of this movie set
design the building from a little after
seven the gun that we actually assembled
a bunch of experts on this issue
and started how what is the relationship
between caliber the air the air quality
the access to natural light and other
features and interactivity and there is
really growing science san diego state
did a pretty systematic review
rebuilders nationwide and think the
chemical dependence provided evidence
that they are reduction absenteeism that
by twenty-five or thirty percent and
activity so people worked at in a better
environment and when you think about
when you think about the economic
relationship between the cost of real
estate in the cost of the people were
sitting in the chairs it's it's it's a
no-brainer because the cost of people
sitting in the chair somebody's
including management
the same pants but 20 is an angle
emulation welcome sweetie so if you can
choose productivity just slightly and if
you can attract the better cow broke out
writ large you've changed the excellent
business much more than back from
flipping over about four to five so that
is the part powerful engine building so
i think actually in looking at four
times square the decisions made about
for tonight square first made by a
sherman because the first time that had
been brought to the
making process for a rigorous
organization and that part of that
giraffe is actually be brought in the
operational staff the engineers could be
working within the building as well as
the people who would be supervising that
staff as well as tissue construction as
many architects and at that time we
didn't have a care in the process to
make sure that they were part of that
because in operating a green or
sustainable building that's the most
important part as you know existing
buildings of these certification will
increase the amount of time that they're
going to retrieve your building so it
doesn't matter how green the technology
you're using that we need to make sure
that your staff has brought has been
rotting early to that process
understands it and then goes forward for
tech square is a really interesting test
he said cuz we looked at by five petals
solid soul and was only 34 on all four
sides of the building 34 a book in the
middle of the building
so let's garage we also put this on
which was not a success the reason they
were not as success is because nobody
else followed who have no one developer
started to use fuel cells within New
York City it has become very difficult
to maintain those fuel cells so in our
practice we like to kick the tires we
try and try and try again this table is
actually made out of bed work um we were
building the halina incidentally named
we've tested manzo'd and the way that we
tested it we put it into a bacon floor
and we started pouring all this stuff on
it stepping on it they can see what I
would do and it ended up cupping so we
went to in renewable certified renewable
of Forest Service
they started
the receiver efficient worked in the
office right yes oh he knows about how
much fun everything isn't just like a
Porsche although I distinctly remember
ticular one food was not a happy
individual in her former boss and I had
many encounters with her and one day
there's something about the air as well
I explained filter its natural
and she was in the dark past she
preferred to dark back then banana she
understood all that money for hannah has
an unbelievable effect and that's what
the earlier studies were talking about
children and test scores of what's
happening with your ability to see
nature from contains troops and trade
it's just abuser spectacular lots of
instructions that other things that are
going on it just for our younger your
acid containing track gills besides the
fact that certain people who commute
they love being in the building but one
of the things is they get those views
that back in her apartment with on top
of each other so you know they they what
was really remarkable is how many our
work force stated because the views at
night or just a spectacular or so and
then add the skyline and we're looking
at Central Park now if everyone can try
to locate that but as I went around the
country any other releases that I was
doing you can't find gold league
buildings or any sort of the buildings
in their kind of easier and I think
marketable actually there's a race
towards quality so better companies will
see these out and you want to see more
do it but I would just look for as much
Pilates and then you know I bring in
recycle materials at the time when we
built the furniture systems besides
getting rid of builder tool time I bring
to you know that kind of stuff where's
the SAS course what are they doing the
furnace was lonely ase certified with
the largest a nail in the United States
and just put it out today they're all
fighting for the competition to be able
to service negotiate that's what you do
for you figure out how far across the
price port is this process how much
prettier and if they can't provide did
you have to work with them and the end
of the day to negotiate services I was
kind of breaking the mold for do stuff
but in
afterwards and it sold so much more
product after losing our in our building
and that's not just for American
companies that's from over a wool
how many of your torso to college one
split up so the big series so when my
father Douglas Durst first builds up
four times square many people all turn
out and said it was not a business
decision but it has become something
that people realize that it makes a lot
of economic sense and so for the first
four years there is a huge building boom
in 2002-2004 there's a great
disappointment not to see many buildings
following suit there was there was
several outliers but after 2000 quiet
became evident that becoming
leed-certified became invoke and that it
was very marker so I think it's been
followed people have started to follow
suit recently I was headed talking
engagement in DC and that York City is
starting to actually start to live out
my new york state slagging of money
several other states the united states
Colorado Denver Colorado California DC
are all following suit and starting to
build
have built by far more 875 builders you
know why you see
so they're in for a reset but if you
don't find them better offices we're all
screwed so really way back was probably
under Clinton administration they
started projecting how many people
believe in hennepin service how they
were going to track people are doing
wasn't it even sabes
very surprised
people
called we stand pretty big distinctions
between what much is up there eat
certified being a very low are compared
to losing the latest based on
convenience of this stuff's pretty cool
and its way they're just good to me
either man yeah okay I think you're
right there are different levels of e
has generally happy variation expect Oh
Lord shucks you can lead certification
versus building lot of the leed standard
was developed with the office parkson so
they've had to develop it more advanced
development as a standard desirable
target for this mission were credited
with the proximity of magic and the fact
that you used recycled rain water to
irrigate five shrubs outside your
building an office park is less should
be less than point or value to the lead
system coastal management and they've
tried to evolve it is still system in
evolution but I think the important
things in stride I just want to stay on
that point for one second so something
that was extremely happy to see in all
the presentations is you all kind of
gave equal weight to issues of
neighborhood if you did to issues of
technology which I was very pleased to
see and we didn't even plan that which i
think is terrific and just interesting
the Atlanta you started with your family
traditions those great decision that
have to be able to walk to all of your
buildings
sort of but and then I think Brian you
talked about the whole transformation of
columbus circle and geometry that that
shot down where I live like a block from
that shot it's an incredible mix you're
actually writing approves of what's
available to be right there but you know
when you look at the future and you've
all had experienced with buildings that
are not these pages right when you show
the old seminole Trade Center talk about
the old service from other parts of the
portfolio and you know you mentioned in
space which is largely not only not
green but you know probably really
miserable by a lot of the standards of
the talked about here at night you know
if you look forward where do you think
we've got sufficient room for growth
right in a large scale or the kinds of
buildings you're talking about past the
Trade Center site if it's in your heart
a lot of these sites it's going to give
us maybe 10 of these buildings in total
when all said gone I mean you really see
the capacity Oh marketers okay well we
were only an assemblage earlier due to
the physical capacity in the city but to
build the office stuff that we need to
figure all talking it's definitely a
very tough question because you have
that I think we should look at first
feeding the structure that we have in
here of City and nonspecific and there's
the issue with the csos there's also
another issue with solid waste as well
as the solid waste if you think about
where that's getting trucked out and
impact in the solid waste and then
probably be doing what we can be doing
solid waste as far as how providing
additional energy the reason that
denmark in therapy in northern european
countries do so well on energy
production in length of the version to
landfill is because they're using their
bio solids as a source of energy so i
think it's looking at it from a resource
point of view I think its first tee
we'll look at the major infrastructure
that new york city has and first
understanding what we are doing to be
impacting none I don't think it's on an
individual developer dveloppement de
bellefort level at that point as you
know there's about public square feet
that's dr. to developed on the Hudson
Yards but I don't know if that would be
the best thing for New York City because
we already impacting overused and fairly
old infrastructure system
we have this great mass transit system
but we aren't focusing our development
and I my only beef is you never preserve
websites for office buildings in mass
rid of that caliber oddity building
quick jabs there's no reason that
somebody who lives in New Jersey at
havas we should be doing more either way
to preserve probably New York jeremy's
and Velvets eyes close to mass transfer
they're probably a public policy effort
to protect some
land which creates insights by
condemnation invention that are close to
that because that is ultimately the
threat to our need to leverage what
we've got the master welcome for mass
transit like the second line extension
so that when your audience are how much
how much flexibility there exists with
the existing stock to make changes to to
sell the builders to retrofit than the
web that logging your substituted for
break would be a farmer to get better
office space where is the technology so
we have about 10 office buildings total
and I think five of them were built
before
16 and the major issue there is space
constraints so to be able to put in the
ice chiller plant fields and all these
wonderful technologies we went 80 feet
deep into the ground floor bryant park
and the entire square footage of the
building is about two acres that
footprint of the buildings about it
about two acres so to be able to put in
additional technology you need to be
able to have the space and it's those
constraints that are the most condemning
the other side of that that point is the
facade and the third load that you're
impacting how much heat and how much
cool air are using in the in the summer
winter months all the sudden level
interest there are some there are some
incentives
discussion about growth in the cost he's
starting to come down the retrofit it is
a 27 very difficult
as for very job I'm just saying that
it's yes you can retrofit some of that
star I agree but there's a play with you
know there is some threshold moment
which because call the report of course
pacing and so forth you're not going to
be class configuration all that you know
is structured with women but if the idea
is to improve existing spaceship on your
cost effective waste your discount
when people sent to me
treehugger are key studies beautiful
commercial we surpassed any projections
us retain and attract the very best
executives are tremendous
magazines websites
words
which is no heart or anything under the
arc is to tear out to be built from
percentage and it also makes economic
sense because heating ventilation air
conditioning systems consume the
majority of a lot of managers power as
well as electrical load which goes
directly to your dollars right so if you
can and help most buildings work is its
with their HVAC system you turn the
light switch on and off you either have
the key on and the whole building is
getting heated or you turn the light
switch out and the whole building is
getting air conditioned there's really
no
ability to to be able to have a certain
tenet of air conditioning and so it is
and that's called constant air volume
and so as tenants and the aesthetics go
away density it makes it easier for
managers and landlords to go throughout
a building and look at your HVAC system
and change it to variable air volume
system which gives people the ability
essentially as a dimmer switch so that
they're able to have their heat go into
what one floor of most to a bacon floor
where their conditioning is the same
thing and that will produce costs as
well as similar entities that's a very
capable new technology and it's becoming
to life and then people are taking
advantage of it and she just explained
to you a very clear concise way not a
market text speak not engineering to
become and the end of the day what's
happening energy-saving love it's a
simple concept you just break it down
together so Austin memories would be
able to build next to or across the
street two blocks away from the crystal
stunning there what happens to be shy
the mostest you know things move to like
places where a long great subway line
and there is a lot of great
transportation proximity to the park it
would be a transformation of the west
side styles of the audience two
questions the first question is as
developers I'd let you know how do you
structure the night so that I know you
all talked it out
me being a good marketing strategy but
how does how you ensure that tenants
follow that / eyes and face maybe they
use the building poverty so that you get
a saving I'm actually doing a case study
off work I'm smart right now I know you
have to but I don't think that we be
impossible or they're actually the
second question is I was here range from
building owner to building design
building development so my second
question is are there any difference in
the way
perspectives so as far as attending
guidelines very difficult so we first
opened up the cortex where we were
actually giving Damaris up to our
tenants for those who decide and if
you've ever had to have a vice president
explain to a cleaning person about how
they didn't want to get it demerit it's
not it's not a pretty situation and so
what we do is we do things that they
don't even realize we've been working
now with godliness to reduce their
plastics usage by taking out everybody
has a desk right and you have two bins
one minute has a plastic liner and the
other it doesn't have a plastic liner
and that's just for paper we told our
all of our tenants in our portfolio that
we were removing the plastic liner
that's reducing plastic right there that
also affects the amount of paper that's
being properly used as far as being
recycled paper is eighty percent of
waste that comes out of an office
building that's not a cafeteria this
paper that is the most valuable material
that comes through the New York City
recycling besides steel as well as any
type of metal but you're getting mostly
paper up out of an office building so
the cleaner you can have your paper with
the less contaminants the less food The
Roar is going to be recycled the second
way is that we have composting conde
nast cafeteria has a cop
duration and none of this has ever
realized by the tendons it isn't third
point is that we have a very strict
green cleaning program we maintain that
all of our very detailed stuff so I
guess remaining that all our vacuum
cleaners and all the cleaning equipment
that's used is well maintained has is
does not use a lot of energy all the men
tell the cleaning products has little
BOC and we try to whatever possible put
in paper products and in bathrooms that
are made out of recycled content I think
that we were saying that challenges they
will respond
we educate it should be simple it's just
shown
is that a lot of companies were penance
they're building suburbs people are not
necessarily building operated so they're
there they're people who try to keep an
office boss happy and on leased facility
so they're not necessarily the start
would have not been people were most
cutting-edge on technology because he
just talking to pay the resident of
eligible and whatnot so part of those
challenges to bring those those puffs
curve so if they understand the
opportunities that are available to that
in this building two models different
what their customers to save money and
operate that in addition to that
understand the world trade center we
have conservative formal systems
actual show look here or the carpet you
can buy and will help you to satisfy me
to learn to take with your steps how
they they can be me certified for their
it is separate from the base though
we've got design ability so that's part
of the process as well and it's worked
in many cases we have several trade
senators that German investment bank
stuffy that image they didn't lead
platinum highest level
green reasons
in that kind something to your own
they'll move towards that the same
location the same the same way they look
at you know numbers factors including
price so you know it depends but again
we were our occupier so it's easy easy
to make great choices with all the
building and especially it easier once
you understand you understand
Lisa's etc I'm satin Utley shocked when
I asked how many lawyers in had their
certification was when I was doing that
I was like and we're talking to eat here
but we all understand what it means
what lead the net for me what it was
just a gun right I have many different
consultants dasilva consultants on the
job on a variety of different things but
my mind's a bit nicer regard state
energy research development corporation
ask for grant to kick-start as they have
no signature prop you know compulsion
boy or a project like this on the next
item the New York City
person became easier and then it becomes
it becomes a better way to understand
all don't have to have laser technology
which moves slowly and truly towards
materials and other things to make your
space
sure you had to replicate the space we
have today is very much a great market
very afraid high 60 low class so it's
dead so it's out the street it was great
in disparities great tale
but you know project can get great
prices in terms of our own
now they were just afraid of doing up
and it was other things Katrina wasn't
wasn't then that is helpful in the
community trying to sell it back in
years so in terms of community approvals
from landmark specific planet from the
MTA is explaining how we build a way
Billy it's going to be better for the
neighborhood it was the caribou and they
came in for everybody brace so the CTO
at thanksgiving event came up to me
so
absolutely so if you take a look at what
Bryant Park is not a building Ryan
Parker Breitbart visiting excellent
possible of how people get together they
hot markets but it gives the office
where there's a place to go and bryant
park has made the surrounding market
much more valuable and a great meter to
keep seeing how well area is doing as
you can see how many women are walking
around so in Times Square before the
revitalization there were pulling the
only the women who are working or
walking around the rest of the rest of
the population walking on the streets
were men and so for people to feel safe
to go to work they didn't want to go
there because you just didn't feel safe
so not only is it more
but also from the safety me I think
public spaces in the building that's
kind of in before we reach towards
extending the social space so low sixth
Avenue we're in the most valuable retail
coach John we decided to make sure that
there was a public space it's called the
urban garden road it's highly news
people love it people go in and they
have they can have a meeting down there
because it's such a pleasant place to be
and reflects the spirit of bryant park
and you're able to go in and enjoy
yourself and also be a little bit of
nature inside that's should be out soon
i have a question it's obviously we we
were thrilled to have planning
I think so essential to making sense of
place
old Seminole Trade Center as gracious
public space and part of the building
they worshiped the one of the challenges
we didn't have much space at the grave
love to work with because the first
three stories of the law are all common
substations massive transformers year
necessary to sustain the electric power
system happy so in some ways I think
it's the park outside its model and in
some ways I look forward to the under
buildings will be filled which have more
of that the dynamism of retail sector
which have Egyptian action both through
pedestrian experience
to the dressing area in which base water
park which is bryan park come one and a
half in size all those trees and
people mad gracious public space
experience
this basic working for putting credit
there a piano or extraordinary sort of
Allah gracious about it set the stage
for the street bridge coming back make
me beautiful sight which i think in turn
we make the site that much more
sustainable because against the
pedestrian environment and connects as
progress north so I find so forth so I
think just some extent aces these
relatively small moves can have very
dramatic we would planning issue that
people cannot huge
there's a metal a black from back
to port authorities are popped it up
even in that huge closet which was kind
of empty again swept closet or miss the
very end and the natural result was as
you walk backs you have this huge walls
growing up the long side Rican festival
the closet was flat but brain naturally
with that and it created additional fact
that the streets in good for this
evening huge separation in the
surrounding community so we fought very
hard the greatest back follow always
that natural path and walking alongside
some place up there
I think communications spaces or just
essential virtues another speech for SD
that original Dilawar norman foster took
me out we created its print space inside
so here we are
this grand green all sorts
builders
farmers and fresh fruit vegetables etc
do the dish i acquire with constantly
using throw really figure out clean
green cleaning saturated in space
there's a theater there there's two art
galleries in people's great engine to
drive people to talk to each other you
aren't just tweeting largest share
innovation in conversation
yeah they need to just wipe away until
they started the company they literally
a picture to the stage foundation and
then go to pot when we look up see the
future and working to create so communal
spaces are very important otherwise it
was the most able to scale which some
people say is in future work I disagree
if you have to create spaces talk to
each other
okay thank Hamels very much for coming
tonight and devious their thoughts in
their time and thank you all for staying
late night that's very important topics
it was very lovely
you